hello everyone welcome to today's career
webinar on understanding applicant
tracking system
i'm meera singh ravath your career coach
and i'm accompanied today by my
colleague jackie as my support partner
she'll be assisting at the back end and
moderating the chat for us thank you
jackie for joining
and supporting please keep an eye on the
chat if anybody has questions i'm sure
you're very
competent to manage that while i'm
talking through the slides
thank you moving on um so before we
begin
let's get to know each other it'll be
lovely if all of you can type your name
and the nanodegree that you are pursuing
and if possible your location
so that everyone gets to know each other
and can connect directly later
i always encourage all my coaches to
visit the student hub
on career hotline chat room every day
and leverage
from the q and a that are being asked
there and also connect and network
with the students on study lounge so
please go ahead and type out your
details in the chat box
and let's see where do we have our
audience today from
so as i can see we've got people from
melbourne
oklahoma germany hungary
nigeria austria right
london okay now you're using those
all right okay please keep typing your
name your nanodegree
and trans all right um
i also see fantastic please keep typing
your names and your nano degrees and
your location and all of you can
um get connected and in the meanwhile
i'll start with the webinar
so now moving on a quick introduction
about me
i'm currently located out of india and i
have close to two and a half decade of
work experience
in senior leadership roles for large
multinational firms and their capitals
with focus on bfsi i'm culturally astute
with extensive experience in bringing
together global stakeholders
i'm known for mentoring coaching and
developing high performance teams
with diverse capabilities i have come
constantly nurtured teams and developed
leaders across my tenure
at previous organizations i'm also a
certified behavior and personality
trainer
specialized in this tools i specialize
in career strategy
interviewing skills and job search you
can
see more details about me either on
linkedin or on my website
so moving on what are our key takeaways
today
we are on slide number four and what can
we expect to gather from the webinar
today
so today what we are going to cover is
importance of application tracking
system software
information about how it works
understanding the working
making ats friendly resumes and key
providers of ats
software systems moving on to the slide
it's the today's agenda slide
this lists the agenda items so
they are almost the same as our key
takeaways so without
waiting for more time on this slide we
are going to move on
to the next slide which is slide number
six
and we have a poll right
so i'm going to be launching the poll
this is a good way to get people to
participate
and to see um
how are we placed so all of you need not
worry this is an anonymous poll
nobody will know who's answering what
let's see what people have got to say
the question on the poll is are you
aware of the role
of an application tracking system
software
yeah and the options which are there are
yes no and maybe so we will just give it
another 30 seconds for everyone to
complete
uh their participation as i said this is
anonymous it is more from the
perspective to see what learnings we can
get
through this webinar based on the
knowledge that we have and this also
makes us understand
how much part of the audience is
actually even aware on the subject yeah
so i'm going to give it another 20
seconds which will
make it one full minute and i will then
end the poll
the question is are you aware of the
role of an application tracking system
software
options are yes no and maybe so now
ending the poll
and almost 100 participation is there
uh and here i end the poll all right
so i'm going to share the results please
write yes on the chat if you are
able to see the result so we have 59
of the audience saying yes 23
saying no and 18 saying maybe
okay we have a mixed bag and which is
good to have right
so i'm glad that more than 50 of the
audience is aware
of the role of ats system and how it's
going to impact us
so with that i end the and the poll and
we move on to
our um next slide
so we are on slide number eight the
first agenda item
what is an applicant tracking system
while you read through the slide i'm
going to give a bit of my own
explanation here
applicant tracking system software is
recruiting software
that can process dozens or even hundreds
of applications
in a fraction of the time it would take
a recruiter
or hiring manager to do the same
manually
ats systems use algorithms to
automatically
find applicants that are the best fit
for a job posting
ats software can also help hiring teams
coordinate one another streamlining the
hiring process
improving the experience for everyone
involved
as its name implies an ats
tracks candidates through the hiring
process it helps the interview
scheduling
issues notifications and alerts and
sends automated emails to candidates
and internal employees such as the
recruiter and hiring manager
and ats is also used to call applicants
and recommend the most qualified
candidates
it may conduct a preliminary analysis of
the applicants to find the best
fit for a job it may also look for
keywords or use
ai type algorithms that run a deeper
analysis of the job applicant
the goal is to speed hr's review
of job applications and resumes so
moving on to the next slide which is
slide number nine
why is ats important so we are now on
slide number 10 moving on
where we have the two images why is ats
important now both the images are very
self-explanatory if you see
and look at them companies are pushing
for
leaner and faster processes
and the same applies to recruiting
process
as well therefore applicant tracking
systems have already engaged the
attention of businesses
90 percent of the fortune 500 companies
are using ats software to bring the best
talent to their companies
a corporate open position posting
receives
250 applications on average and 88
percent of these resumes are
unqualified this form of resume
requires a high volume of resources and
time
according to gartner recruiters spend
one quarter of their time
with resume screening along with the
volume of applications
human bias is also another reason why
organizations prefer ats for hiring
recruiters may have an unconscious bias
against a certain gender race
etc when a recruiter does not scan all
resumes in the same manner qualified
applicants may get rejected with an
applicant tracking system
recruiters can spend less time on resume
screening
and have a better chance of removing
buyers from their decisions
so moving on to the next slide and we
continue on the same subject
why is ats important as seen below
organizations that use ats report
that they increased the productivity of
recruiters
and higher per month while decreasing
time to hire
and report generation time we can see on
the slide the picture
how 75 percent decrease and how we had
15 percent decrease in time to fill
70 percent increase in report generation
speed and 10
increase in placements per month moving
on to the next slide which is slide
number
um 12 which is the agenda slide and we
will again go and have one more poll
so the people who have joined in late
here is another chance for you
all to join in one more poll so we are
going to
uh now launch another poll and
this will be the second poll of the
evening and here we go
i have launched the poll go for it the
question on the poll is do companies
benefit by investing
in application tracking system software
there are three options yes no maybe
it's an anonymous poll feel free to
express your
view whatever information knowledge that
you have
and there are no right or wrong answers
we are here to learn
so all the answers are great so i'm
going to give it another 20 seconds for
everybody to join in
and complete this so that we make sure
that we have the whole audience actually
uh giving their view out
so 10 more seconds and almost we are
done
the question is do companies benefit by
investing in application tracking system
software
and yes we have house full and 100
people have voted
and i'm ending the poll and i'm going to
present the results please type yes in
the chat if you're able to see the
results now fantastic so the score is
that 73 percent say yes
eight percent say no and 23
are in middle maybe again great
let's move on to our next slide which is
um why do companies invest
in applicant tracking system technology
the same subject continues
so the statistics again on the slide are
self-explanatory
seventy percent faster report creation
seventy five percent lesser time wasted
in hiring process
fifteen percent reduction in time to
fill and ten percent more placement per
week
eighty six percent recruiters say that
using ats has helped them
hiring faster 78 percent say that they
are able to hire
better quality of hires right moving on
to the next slide
why do companies invest in applicant
tracking system technology we still
continue on the same subject slide
number 15
atss share a number of general
streamlined hiring features in common
that are listed on the slide
companies invest as
they increase the volume of applicants
ats software can make it fast and easy
to post position
openings to multiple job boards career
pages
and social sites which can increase the
resume volume greatly
it allows the company to view data for
recruitment optimization
ats software tracks all the hiring data
and makes it easy to view using
reporting
and analytic functions being able to
look over the recruiting data in new
ways can provide the company
with valuable insights that may have
otherwise been overlooked
it assists with managing and filtering
resumes
ats software uses keywords and semantic
search technology
to help filter out resumes of the wrong
candidates
i target view and track the resumes of
those best suited for the position
now that we have understood this we will
move on to the next agenda
item which is how does applicant
tracking software system work
so we will have a poll here again and
i'm going to now present the third poll
of the evening
and here we go i have launched the poll
it's anonymous
please go for it the question here now
for the poll
is if 200 applicants have applied for
the job
how many applications get reviewed by
the fr
staff now that's an interesting question
we all are aware
that on an average there are 200 to 250
people applying
for every single job vacancy that comes
up
the million dollar question is how many
of those applications are actually seen
by a human
or by a hr person because we are in a
digital era and
the first screening is done by the
software so at the end
how many do actually get to see the eye
of a hr
person so um we still have a few people
who are yet to complete and respond to
the poll this poll is anonymous
please feel free to give your view it's
just statistical and it is always
interesting
to see how much of it people know and it
also differs from
location to location so it's good to get
the views
we have multiple choice answers over
here the question
is if 200 applicants have applied for
the job
how many applications get reviewed by
the hr staff
all right so we have now uh
almost 98 of the people have voted so
i'm just waiting i don't know who's that
one person who hasn't voted but uh oh
yeah
now we got house full i'm going to end
the poll and i'm going to present the
results please type yes if you can see
the results on the
chat so we have four percent saying that
hundred percent get viewed by a chart
four percent say
seventy eighteen percent say fifty
applications get viewed by a chart
64 say 25
and 14 percent say none so i would like
to give some statistics in my upcoming
slides
um i would go more with the 64
percentile audience
that yes about 25 applicant applications
do get viewed by the hr people and we
will see it in the subsequent slides
so let's move on uh to the next slide to
see some statistics
so uh moving on to slide number 18
while the infographic on the slide is
self-explanatory
let's have a look at how does this ats
software work
as a career coach i often hear from job
seekers
who are frustrated by the lack of
response from employers
what many of them don't realize however
is
that oftentimes the hiring manager never
received
their job application let me explain
before your job application is passed
along to the hiring manager
it first has to be reviewed by one if
not two
initial gatekeepers an electronic screen
known as applicant tracking system and
the junior level
hr coordinator in both these cases
the gatekeeper has been instructed to
scan the document for
important pieces of information and
terms
related to the role at hand if the
resume meets the criteria
it will pass through the screen and make
its way to the next reviewer
either an experienced recruiter or
hiring manager
who will have a better understanding of
your work and capabilities
if you're resuming does not make it past
these initial gatekeepers the hiring
manager
is never made aware of your application
and this infographic very beautifully
describes it
i'm sure all of you by now have gone
through the infographic
and uh we can see that 1000 people
notice
a job posting online 200 people apply
100 complete the application process 25
applicants are reviewed by a hiring
manager
so it's almost similar to what the poll
results were
64 percent of the audience today on the
webinar also said
that out of 200 applications about 25
get viewed by a hiring manager
so we were taught online right um
i'm sorry i can hear somebody who has
not muted his or her microphone
i'll request whoever is not on mute to
please mute it thank you
and finally four to six candidates are
invited
to interview for the opening and one or
three
reach the final round and after that
only one gets selected
so that's information and statistics for
us
let's move on to the next slide um
how applicants can beat application
tracking system
and what better way than to start it
with a poll all right
so here we go and we are going to start
with
our last goal of the day in fact because
after this we are going to get into real
intense slides
i'm going to launch the poll this is
anonymous and the question is
is your resume ats friendly
go ahead and take a take a chance on
writing
think about it how many of you have
actually worked towards making it ats
friendly
how many of you haven't and how many of
you are not aware
so the question is is your resume ats
friendly
options are yes no not sure
so we have a hundred percent
people responding and i'm ending the
poll and i'm sharing the results please
type yes if you can see the report
other the results on the chat so we have
10 persons saying yes
great fantastic kudos uh to all those 10
percent of the people
28 percent say no welcome to the webinar
and here you're going to learn
how to have the strategies and 62
percent say not sure
that's a large audience which is a good
place to be
because in all probability you may be
actually incorporating quite a few of
these elements
already knowingly or unknowingly so
let's get to know
what are the strategies what are the
do's and what are the don'ts
so i'm going to stop sharing the results
and i'm going to get into the next slide
now
all right so moving on to slide number
21 how
applicants can beat applicant tracking
system software
this slide is the summary of all the
do's and don'ts for making your resume
ats friendly we will be covering each of
these components in detail in the
following slides
it's a beautiful infographic and hence i
put it up it's kind of a synopsis
so let's move on to the next slide as we
get into each and every dimension of
that summary slide
so moving on to slide number 22 the
first one
the key point to be noted is use
resume keywords correctly on the left
hand side of the slide have a look at
the example
of using keywords correctly this is one
of the most crucial elements to not only
get your resume past the ats
but to ensure that it gets a high
ranking as well
the software is designed to scan for
keywords that relate to the job
and industry a good place to start would
be the job description
if you're going for a job within a
particular industry you should already
have identified the major keywords
that relate to that industry or the
position that you seek
if you need some guidance you can look
at a few job descriptions which will
help you decide
which keywords to include in your resume
one thing that's
just as bad as not having the correct
keywords
is overusing them many applicants
try to staff as many keywords as they
can
in hope of beating the ats and earning a
high ranking
nice try it won't happen the ats will
reject an
overstuffed resume as quickly as it
would
a resume with insufficient keywords so
work on finding the right balance in
your resume
also please don't try to do ghost
writing don't try to do white
font writing it doesn't work at all
straight away your
applications will be rejected the second
generation ats system softwares
are far more intelligent and they can
detect all of this
and they will straight away reject your
applications moving on to the next slide
now we are on the second crucial element
format your resume correctly for ats
stick to a traditional resume format at
all times
this ensures that your resume can be
scanned by the ats
and that it is easy for a recruiter to
read
there are three basic resume formats
acceptable for use
the first one is the reverse
chronological this is the most popular
format
this is the most popular resume format
and is ideal for someone
who has a good work history and is
staying in the same line of work
functional this resume format is ideal
for those who have
large employment gaps or plan on
switching industries
basically career transition a functional
resume format
allows you to lead with skills and
qualifications
instead of work experience you can also
find your article
on writing a good functional resume here
the third way is hybrid format this is a
combination
resume format of a reverse chronological
and a functional format
it allows you to use the best features
of both formats
however if you have a large employment
gap
or very little experience you should
avoid this format
moving on to next slide slide number 24
the third element
send the correct type of file
send the correct file type applicant
tracking system needs to be able to scan
and read your resume
the safest way to ensure that your
resume will be read
is to submit it in a dot doc or
dot x file from microsoft word
even though many of the systems are now
advanced enough
to read a pdf you should still send a
dot
doc file to be on the safe side a dot
doc file is the preferred file
type for both ats and many recruiters
you should always check the job
description to see
if the employer wants a certain file
type
oftentimes employers will specify a
certain file type
so you should always have a dot doc and
a pdf version
of your resume on file ready moving on
to the next slide slide number 25
the fourth element label sections
on your resume correctly keep looking on
the left hand side of the slide for the
examples
so you need to ensure that the system
can read
all the sections of your resume
correctly
label your resume sections properly
using standard headings
such as work experience education and
interest
verify that the location position and
length of employment
information that you provide is clear
and consistent throughout your resuming
if your layout is not done properly
the ats may have trouble identifying
where you were what you did and how long
you were there
and that obviously will not go in your
favor
yeah moving on to the next slide slide
number 20
include relevant information the ats
scans your resume to determine
if it contains relevant information and
experience
for a specific job don't submit two
pages of experience from a sales
position
for an accounting job the ats will
most likely reject you because your
resume contains
very little relevant information
if you don't have any relevant
experience try to include
education skills or even
reword your past experience
so it's relevant to the position you can
leverage your transferable skills
to better match what this job is looking
for
yeah now i have done
a webinar on transferable skills which
is available on udacity youtube channel
and also on my own youtube channel
make it a point to go through the
transferable skills webinar
below every webinar you will find
resource links and resource articles
so go through the webinar recording to
understand the concept
application and benefits and go through
the resource articles to understand how
to implement the concept
so going through transferable skills
will help you deal with this particular
element of
ats software system moving on to the
next slide
sixth element use a popular and
professional font
for ats scanning so stick to a
that an ats can process this is not only
important for enabling the ats to
process
your application correctly but is also
vital
for retaining a recruiter's interest
you have to remember that if a recruiter
reviews your resume
it will be a major turn off to see a
font like comic sans
on the left hand side of the slide a
suggestive list of fonts is shared
so i'm going to just pause for probably
a few seconds or a minute
for you to actually see what are the
fonts and maybe think in your mind
if you have been using one of these
fonts or something
outside this list if it is outside this
list
then it's a good welcoming information
for you guys after this webinar
wherever you are go and do a rain check
when do a sense check on how your resume
looks like
on each of these elements right
okay so now we move on to the next slide
which is slide number 28
avoid fancy designs colors
and images this ties in with formatting
but it's something we need to mention
because we see it so often
one of the tip here that i can suggest
is don't put fancy colors
images or fonts on your resume
not only does it create a problem for
the ats but recruiters also not
do not really like it much moving on to
the next slide
this is the eighth element and slide
number 29
avoid spelling and grammar errors
like the plague 58 percent of the
resumes contain
spelling and grammatical errors
according to a career builder survey
when i am talking to my clients and my
coaches
i often see grammatical errors in the
linkedin profile
so it's a very human error but we need
to be mindful
when we are submitting a application for
a job
or a vacancy because ats detects it
and this becomes one of the negative
scoring for you
so spelling errors can cause a resuming
to be automatically rejected the
majority of recruiters
will also dismiss a resume even if it
contains only a single error
microsoft words spell check
is not enough to correct all your
spelling and grammatical errors
you should read over your resume a
couple of times
and even have a friend or a professional
look it over and one more tip that i can
give you here
is print out your resume to proofread it
so how many of you guys actually
do read your resume a couple of times to
check out
what kind of dramatical errors is there
just type on the chat
um and how many of you actually
proofread it by taking a printout
it will be fantastic to uh to see
what practice is everybody doing yeah so
go ahead and type on the chat how many
of you what kind of
activity do you do to make sure that
your application
your your resume does not have
grammatical errors
so type out your responses on chat and
we will know and everybody will learn
if there is something new i mean all of
us can learn from it right
so i do see uh one of the participants
saying i get someone else to read it
i can't always see my own errors very
well said you're absolutely right
i always say that i can only correct the
document
thrice if i read it the fourth time my
eye will not be able to catch the error
so
i see again somebody else says i use
grammarly
and also have a friend to read it very
good another student e day says i
usually ask someone else to proofread in
case i have missed something
absolutely a fresh pair of eyes always
helps you know
we are so invested in our own
application
that we may not really be able to read
or see the
errors so it's always good to have it
proofread by somebody else
i see gokul saying self-proof reading on
print out
it's good to see that you know some of
you are actually taking a physical
printout because
even today although it's a digital world
the fast-moving executives who are
on the run and they are moving from one
meeting to another
at times they are just handed the
handouts in a printed format
when they are coming to interview a
student uh sorry then they're coming to
interview a candidate
after a couple of their meetings so it's
always a good idea
to even take a printout of your resume
to see how it looks like
when a printout is taken and you'll be
surprised
more than often that something that
couldn't catch the naked eye when it was
digitally in front of your eyes on the
system
it comes out very glad glaringly when
you look at it in a
print format so um i see nibs
car saying that i ask a friend to check
it and again one more
student saying using grammarly so mostly
people are doing a mixed bag of all
of these which is great all right so
moving on to the next slide
which is slide number 13. the eighth
the next important element spell out
all abbreviations so be cautious about
abbreviating words titles or
certifications
on your resume if you do abbreviate
make sure you spell out the abbreviation
as well
you don't need to spell out
abbreviations every time
but make sure that you spell it out at
least once
this ensures that whether the ats is
scanning for the full word
or the abbreviation your resume has both
the ats may also be unable to recognize
certain abbreviations like cpa instead
of c
dot p dot a when in doubt reference the
job posting
and copy the style used there so i'll
pause for a minute on this slide because
it is important
we all assume that we know
what the abbreviation means but it's not
the question of we knowing
it's the question of the reader knowing
the software knowing
the interviewer knowing and the hiring
manager knowing right
so be mindful that your application
is not for you but for the person who's
going to be seeing it reviewing it and
assessing it
so we want to make it very easy for
anyone who's reading our resume
and not misread and not misinterpret any
part of it
right so you can see there are certain
examples which have been put up over
here
so for example mr boulevard corporation
and ph
new york now who everyone will say who
doesn't know and why
well welcome to the real world the ats
tracking system
may not appreciate it right all right so
let's move on to the next slide
and we are on slide number 39
make sure that your resume file name is
correct
yes what you name your file
matters even though it might get through
the ats
recruiters will often ignore
unprofessional resume names
use your first and last name or a
combination of the two
you should also add either the word
resume
or the position you seek this is also
important because if recruiters need to
go back
and find you in the system they can
easily do so
by searching your name in the database
this
also holds true if someone is referring
you
for the job your resume needs to be
easily
found should the recruiter want to pull
up your file
most recruiters won't do the work for
you
and rename the file so make sure you
have the correct file name
so how many of you have actually paid
attention
to naming your file correct that would
be very interesting to see
so please type on the chat that how many
of you or
how do you name your file before
submitting an application or hitting
that apply button
do you use one of these formats which
has been explained on the slide here
do you put the name of the position do
you put your name and date
do you put the name of the company or
you have not thought about it
at all that's also fine so i see one of
the students saying
i have never paid attention to this
never thought about it at all
lisa also says yes e day says i use my
first and last name
michael says i have never paid attention
zubair says i never do
it usually is something like zacv9
all right welcome to the real world guys
and
somebody wrote resume dot doc
okay um another
participant says usually only last name
andre says first and last name my dota
says always used first last name cv
nibs that's a good practice name and
roll format
katrina says last name first name resume
or cv
that's good too uh siddhu says first
name and last name
so most of us usama says first name
along with the designation
and company now that's that's a big one
that's a great one yeah
you kind of put everything so nothing
will be missed here fantastic
okay so we have a mixed bag so see
amongst ourselves
itself see how each one of us
knowingly or unknowingly is either doing
the right thing
or is ignorant and not doing it right
ignorance is never an excuse right for
anything
so now that you have been a part of this
webinar and you know
that how important it is to name your
file correctly henceforth not only for
applications
but even in general whenever you're
submitting a document
make sure that you're naming it
correctly so sometime
you yourself may want to search for that
file and it will become easier for you
to search
if we give common names it becomes very
difficult
for uh you also and for the receiver
also to search
like for example when i am doing my
coaching and when i give a framework
and when um clients or students come
back
and they share the work from the
previous session and
most of them just named the file as
research.doc now i have hundreds of
documents
which are named as research.doc now even
if i genuinely want to pull out two or
three or
four to show and share it with
other participants and clients and
students so that they can learn from
them
it becomes a nightmare for me to
actually remember
or make out which one is who's and which
one is good
right but if if people start putting
just their name
or maybe you know something unique it
becomes easy for the receiver
so now i have started renaming my files
based on you know
what is the nano degree for which the
student has done the research
and that way i have tagged it
appropriately
and i pull it up and i share it in my
coaching sessions
to other students so that they can learn
by seeing
now this is an example for you to learn
from that in future when you are naming
a file
whether it is for your reference whether
it is for a job application
or whether it is for anything make sure
that you're naming it in such a
structured manner
that it will be easy for anyone to pick
it up
so moving on to our next slide make sure
you are qualified for the job
to sum it all up make sure you meet the
qualifications of the job hosting
blindly sending out tons of resumes is a
waste of your time
yeah it's better
to take your time and go through each
job description
to verify that you're qualified i get a
lot of clients who come and tell me
meera i have been applying but i don't
get a response
i had somebody earlier last week
he said i have applied for 100 job
applications
over a period of four months and i have
not received a response from single one
so we all know now about the notorious
black hole called ats
now if you are not qualified for the job
if you are not able to
tell your story right if you're not able
to showcase your portfolio or your
projects appropriately
how do you expect a recruiter or a ats
software system
to actually shortlist or screen you i
always tell everybody
this is a digital world and everybody is
watching your digital footprint
what story are you telling what personal
brand are you building
so i have done a webinar on personal
branding and i have given some amazing
resource
articles and links in the even
description
so go and check out the webinar on
personal branding
and it will tell you not only the role
it plays in job search and career
transition
it will also help you to build step by
step your personal brand
make sure that you go through each job
description
you do the compatibility matching of the
score
you have so many softwares available
that can help you
to not only find out the keywords but
also tell you a matching score
a compatibility score make sure that you
have
at least 80 percent compatibility score
or more
before you apply for the job given the
pandemic situation today
there are hundreds of applicants sitting
over there talented and experienced ones
who are raising their hand for junior
jobs as well now
in that pool of people if you are not
eight on ten
what are the chances that ats will
screen and shortlist your profile
we saw in the earlier slides when
thousand people look at an application
200 people complete
from these 200 only 25 reach the hiring
manager
and the reason for this is are you
qualified for the job
are you eight on ten the atheist is
designed to see
if the candidate is a good match for the
job and verify
that he or she has the qualifications
needed
however don't be discouraged from
applying for jobs where you meet most of
the qualifications
if a position asks for two years of
experience
and you only have one go for it anyway
yeah it will not harm you at all
now moving on to the last slide of the
webinar today
this is the market share of top ats
solution providers take a minute
to actually look at it
process the information there is a whole
lot of information available on this
slide for you guys
yeah and what do we learn from this
slide can anyone
i would love to see the answers on the
chat
looking at this slide what comes to your
mind
please type on the chat i would love to
see
how different minds think differently so
what comes to your mind when you look at
the slide
all right i see a lot of people
responding
um high demand for ats solution you're
absolutely right kml
so many options yes lisa and you thought
they were
see this is so much knowledge and our
ignorance sometimes you know is bliss
right but not in this case yes there are
so many and more are coming
um yes zubair a lot of different
solutions
yes he did michael says uh different
countries
absolutely different countries different
size of organizations
different scale of operations
the ats softwares are used based on
multiple dimensions
i see uh rejoicing multiple platforms
leading to difficulty in standardization
of ats principles
even within the products yes the joy you
just nailed it you're absolutely right
many algorithms so you may that is the
reason what
i have provided today in the webinar is
a very generic
and core requirement of ats because
there are so many ats software providers
in the market today
each one of them has different filters
yeah
and osama you're right talio is the
highest has the highest
share so those of you who are interested
now that you know the names
of so many providers you can actually go
and do a little research on your own
self
and see in which countries which uh
software is being used
and why talu is the most popular or
highest
share in the market today yeah uh ishaan
says we have to be dynamic to beat ats
well we have to be dynamic in every way
not only to beat ats
even to compete with the competition in
real life isn't it
it's not about just ats being dynamic is
a way of life
correct um yes andre i agree with you
that
what vijay has mentioned was excellent
um yes so good
i'm happy to see that you all guys found
value on the slide
because while i was putting the slide up
together
um i made somebody proofread it and that
person asked me
you know why have you put up this slide
over here i said well
everybody knows this is a webinar about
ats
but how many of them actually know that
there are so many solution providers and
players in the market
it's a good to have information whether
they want to note it
or they want to ignore it is their
choice so i'm glad that you know
all of you do have a opinion and view on
this
so here i have put on chat a few things
for you to take down in case you want to
go through uh the other webinars etc
now moving on to the last
section of our webinar
here are the take away resource links
so this slide in most of my webinars i
always give take away resource links
and i am going to be posting them right
now on the chat for the students who are
participating today
and for those who will be viewing the
recording you all will be able to see
um the uh the details
even on um the recording and in the even
description
so those who are today present let me
give you the benefit of taking this back
home today
for participating live and i'm going to
be pasting it on the chat
feel free to pick that up from there and
happy reading to all of you
i have practically given an example of
everything that you could be
hoping to have while making your
application
ats compliant right
so there you go these are all the
resource links
that are for takeaway and as you can see
i have given a resource link on how to
test your resume for ats there are three
resources how recruitment chat boxes
chat bots are revealed regulation review
revolutionizing the talent acquisition
landscape
now this was an interesting article i
came upon when i was researching this
webinar
and i thought it would be good to put it
up over here for those
who are good readers avid readers who
like to learn more
so it's a very interesting article so go
ahead and see what is there in store for
us
as a revolution resume keywords what you
need to know
again i have given you a resource link
there and how does
ats impact hiring and how to make ats
friendly resume so with all of these by
your side
and the webinar slides today i'm sure
all of you are feeling a little more
confident than you started
when we started our webinar the next
slide moving on to the next slide it's
the credit slide for all the research
that i have done
and for all the websites i have looked
upon
before actually putting up these slides
together right
and finally we come to our next and the
last session
which is q a so here we come to the
segment
go ahead and ask away and let me try my
best to answer
as many questions as i can during the
time that we have
if there are questions that we are
unable to answer due to paucity of time
please feel free to ask on the student
hub and we all coaches will be happy to
pick them up from there
so now the floor is to you guys please
go ahead and ask away your questions
and i'll try my best to answer them
so do you have any questions for today
so christopher is asking
do cover letters still matter with these
systems
our letters do not really mat
again it is from location to location so
for example in germany
it is imperative and mandatory to have a
photograph
on the resume right and most of the ats
software systems will say
photograph is not required so depending
on the country that you are in
that the cover letter will matter or it
will not matter
the ats will only screen the resume the
ats will not screen the cover letter
but if you are among the shortlisted
candidates
then your cover letter and your
application or your resume
both will go to the hiring manager so
it's all about how you are leveraging
the space and cover letter to tell a
story
that you are not able to put in your
resume so i would always encourage
please do attach a cover letter because
if you are among the shortlisted
candidates
hiring manager is definitely going to
read your cover letter and you can
capitalize on that space and tell your
story
i hope that answers your question
christopher
so we have another question why dota
says
can you tell us where can we see more
resume types examples
so are you saying that you want to know
some resume sample softwares is that
what you're asking
and jackie if you can pull some of the
resources
on resume samples we do have a lot of
resume sample
resources that we can share with you um
so while i look at the other questions
jackie are you able to pull out
something from our resources and share
it over you please
okay we have one more question
do you think a small company of around
20 employees uses
ats very good question
i it depends again on their
turnover it depends again on
the size and the type of company it is
the kind of delivery they are into
um and it's not so much about how many
number of
employees they have as much as the kind
of resources they are trying to source
but if the company itself has just 20
employees and they're not planning to
grow
i don't think they would be investing in
a software like this
because investing in the software is an
investment by itself and maintaining it
is also an investment
so no i don't think that size of a
company would be using an ats software
yeah mira i'll just add to that yes
that's correct so
certain small size companies nightmare
is just saying
the investment is just too much for them
so small to medium size
and there are some medium-sized
companies that don't use it either
um however yes once you get to your
large-sized companies your googles your
facebook
all of those type of companies will all
be using this type of software
so it's not just linkedin and recruiters
it's also some of your larger companies
and some medium-sized companies
but the smaller the company the less
likely they are to rely on this
thank you jackie thank you for sharing
that so i hope you got your answer there
right now we have one more question from
e day
as someone who's transitioning into a
different career
how do i make my cv relevant to the job
so in one of the slides e day i have
explained a functional
a chronological and a hybrid resuming
you could go in for a functional or a
hybrid resume
and if you want to know more about this
one either you could research
or if you have one-on-one career
coaching session available
feel free to book that or you could even
come on the hotline chat
every day one of the coaches comes on
the student hub for one hour
to give online advice on career issues
so more than happy
to give you more resources on that on
how to make a resume
when you're trying to transition your
career yeah
nibs has a question can you share which
all resume color combinations will not
be considered fancy
well i don't have that really handy up
front nibs
but i'll definitely look up if that kind
of information is available
basically i would say any loud colors
usually it's the blues the grays the
blacks the whites
which are acceptable any loud colors are
definitely a no-no nobody likes to look
at them
yeah but i upfront do not have this
information
i'll try to look up for it and if i find
i'll post it on the student subnets
or you could even send me a one-liner
email so that i can send it to you
directly
or you could post a direct message to me
on the student hub
and i will definitely come back to you
on that is that okay with you
mira just to add to that i think when it
comes to the colors it's more thing of
you will sometimes find that people
who have technical resumes um when
they're talking about the type
of um solution or the type of of
expertise they have so if it's r or if
it's python they tend to use the symbol
for r and they tend to use the symbol
for python so the problem is that you're
introducing whilst it looks pretty
you're introducing these kind of logos
which then can throw the system out so
that that tends to be more
the problem okay so that's another angle
that you guys might want to consider
since all of you are a technologist
or applying for technical jobs thank you
for that jackie
um yes we have one more question
from vijoy how to test your resume for
applicant tracking system
when i use these i need to aim for 100
or close to it
for match or like you said earlier we
should not overdo keywords
so 50 match is good so with your in the
resources which i have given us take
away
i have given you the softwares where you
can put your resume and test it
whether it is ats compliant or not it's
a very easy thing to do
after you have complied with all these
10 elements that we discussed today
put it up in the submit it into the
software and it will tell you the score
of your ats compatibility
yeah 50 match is not good
50 match is not good for anything we
join you need to be at least at 80
okay all right
um uh so
great so we have another three minutes i
could take one more question
if anybody has anything on mind i would
also love to
hear your views on how did you find the
webinar and
was there some information that
surprised you was there something new
that you learned today
and uh overall does this really
help you to putting forward your best
foot now
when you're going to be applying for the
jobs or submitting your application
please type your views on the chat it'll
be lovely to see
and yes in the meanwhile what i could do
is uh
[Music]
so i see christopher thanks christopher
uh i'm glad that you found this
information
helpful aladdin says absolutely it was
amazing and helpful
i do a lot of research i tried to bring
in a lot of
content which is to the point and in
addition to that
i also bring in resources so that you
can do after reading
because usually what happens is when
you're listening you're using only four
skills uh four muscles
when you're actually reading yourself
you will be using eight muscles
so i hope the resource articles further
help you in
uh cementing what you learned today so i
see
frederick uh ebay saying definitely just
learned about the number of ats
providers
didn't know this before very helpful
webinar all right
frederick says i had no idea that
companies used systems like that
so this webinar was really helpful and
interesting to know
what yota says where can we see
where can we see some correct hybrid
chronological
and other type of resume examples all of
this is available on google if you
actually just type the type of
resume that you're looking for so the
easiest way to search will be
on google if you just put hybrid resume
samples and you will get a hybrid one
and so is for chronological and source
for functional
you will get the examples and then you
can read through them
and you can learn from them and make
your own yeah
andre says i'm currently studying with
udacity their career chat referred
current students to this webinar
okay lovely that's good this webinar is
open even to alumini
for for for that matter uh for the
students who are actively enrolled and
also for the students who are
alumina who have completed there but
this is going to be one of the last
webinars i believe
so i'm glad that all of you could make
it and we have come to an
end of our uh webinar today i really
enjoyed
um putting up this pack and putting up
the subject together and doing the
research
because it helps you to refresh a lot of
things that i went through my
um corporate times you know even i did
not know so much of
it so maybe by luck i reached wherever i
reached in life
but when i do these webinars and when i
read and when i do research
i do learn a lot so it's it's always
interesting to do these webinars and to
meet
participants and students because we all
learn from each other
so it will be hap i'll be happy to see
all of you if you have any one-on-one
career coaching sessions available
please go ahead and book them the
sundown date is 25th march make the most
of it
you have jackie and me here and then you
go on the scheduler you'll find many
more coaches over there
feel free to take your pick your time
zone and pick your coach
and we'll be happy to join your journey
thank you for joining and thank you